>>Narrator: The Environmental and
Spatial Technology Initiative, EAST,
is an elective class offered
in schools around the country.
Students use the latest technology to
complete projects of their own design
that often serve their community.
>>Sarah: And then we contacted
the people who owned the rights.
>>Narrator: Emma and Sarah are
eighth graders at Little Rock,
Arkansas' Horace Mann Middle School.
>>Teacher: You two look a lot alike.
>>Narrator: They have produced a
ten-minute historical documentary,
which is about to be judged in
a national EAST Competition.
>>Teacher: We'll be showing the
film, and we watch it together,
and then we'll have a
couple of questions for you.
>>Emma: Edith and Ms. Monroe are
leaving today in government boats.
We're going to litter
off [inaudible].
I went riding yesterday.
It sure was fun.
>>Emma: I did most of the editing.
Sarah was more of the
sidekick on there.
>>Sarah: Yeah, I am the writer.
I'm the organizer.
I don't-- I can edit if I
need to, but I prefer not to.
I just tell her what to do.
>>Emma: And there was one paragraph
that she had the hardest
problem hearing.
>>Sarah: Most problem hearing.
>>Emma: No, the hardest.
>>Emma: When we started making the
movie, I didn't really notice it,
but now, when I watch a
movie, I suddenly realize,
"Now, that's a good cut-away.
That's good editing.
You know, that's a good sound."
>>Sarah: For the first time
on record, all the tributaries
of the Mississippi
flooded at the same time,
adding to the steady
rise of the water.
>>Emma: In class, I write a report.
In EAST, I make a movie.
I can't remember history.
I know who some of these people are,
but I can't remember what they did.
In EAST, I know what I
did, because I did it.
I made it real.
>>Deanne: Okay, what
you've just been reading
about are reformers who've
been opposing slavery.
>>Emma: I love my history teacher.
My history teacher's wonderful,
but she can't give me the
things that EAST can give me.
She can't give me hands-on
experiences.
>>Deanne: This is just a
survey course of US History.
And this is a very structured course.
The curriculum is set
by state standards.
It's a problem sometimes when you let
kids just take something that they
like and they run with it.
You know, I'm responsible
for making sure
that they have covered
all of that material.
And in EAST Lab, she gets to
take whatever she likes, usually,
and then she can run with it.
There's much more freedom down there.
>>Emma: She shows me the
book, and she says, "Read it."
I read it.
I fill out a worksheet.
But here, I actually have to turn
in something more than just paper.
>>Teacher: Oh, very
cool, sweet, super sweet.
>>Teacher: How much
interview minutes did you log?
>>Sarah: Oh, at least
an hour-and-a-half.
>>Emma: Yeah, at least.
>>Sarah: Because Mr. Jones...
>>Teacher: With each person?
>>Emma: Yes.
>>Sarah: Well, no.
>>Emma: A lot of them
were just dribble.
>>Emma: I felt so proud of myself,
because I don't know
most of the information.
It's mostly Sarah.
But when they started asking,
you know, "How many people died,
and what was the worst ones?"
You know, I was like,
"I know that stuff.
You know, I know it.
I can tell them."
>>Sarah: We had something
like a hundred sources.
>>Emma: Our packet of files that
Sarah highlighted, about this big.
We have so much information.
Every person, at least one of them
gave us a picture, or a packet.
>>Sarah: Well, one of
them gave us the clips.
>>Emma: Yeah, those wonderful
clips that made our movie.
>>Sarah: I know that I've
become a better public speaker,
and I know that I'm more
comfortable around strangers now.
I'm not so afraid to
show off what I've done.
>>Teacher: Good job, girls.
>>Emma: Great.
>>Teacher: Great job, yeah, good job.
>>Sarah: Thanks.
>>Teacher: All right!
>>Teacher: It was great to
work with these young people.
We particularly have been so
impressed with the quality
of the films that are
coming out of the EAST Labs
from around this country.
And our winning documentary film
is, "Watching the Waters Rise,"
Horace Mann Magnet School,
Emma Baylon and Sarah Baylon.
>>Sarah: We just won the Hot
Springs Documentary Film Festival
first prize!
Shock!
>>Emma: Excited!
Yes!
>>Sarah: It's like a bubble!
<laughs>
>>Emma: No, yeah, bubble.
>>Sarah: Yeah, yeah,
that's could work.